girardot et le cerro bon soir bonsoir
vous êtes tous les deux des acteurs
chevronnés des grandes vedettes et vous
avez craqué hier soir je craquais parce
que d'abord j'ai comme une électrique je
ne pouvais plus me retenir j'étais vous
savez bien qu'on peut avoir quelque
chose et on ne tenait pas la voir mais
je sais pas il s'est passé quelque chose
se séparent et puis ce qui m'a touché
j'ai dit ce que je pensais je veux dire
c'est parce que c'est vrai que que tout
ça m'a manqué mais je n'en ai jamais
parlé mais ce qui m'a touché le plus ces
interventions de michel serrault voilà
parce que j'étais en plus sur le plateau
puisqu'on devait après c'était la fin de
cérémonie donc je l'attendais et j'ai
dit mais thiago silva il flairé répit
d'assolement pourquoi il est ému j'ai
pas compris tout de suite et pour moi
c'est encore plus merveilleux voilà je
voulais le remercier parce que c'est
quelqu'un que j'estime que je connais
bien vont se connaît déjà de vue bien
bien longtemps et c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui est sa folie et ce qu'est ce que
j'aime en lui parce que avoir une folie
comme ils la cèdent hier qu'il est
présent il sait être émouvant il sait
faire les choses qui doit faire mais en
même temps il à cette folie qui
l'isolent justement du train train
quotidien o peut-être à tout à chacun
ausy maintient on se laisse peut-être un
peu aller lui pas d'un feu d'artifice
il échappe c'est extraordinaire alors
michel serrault vous qui manier
tellement bien le l'humour le deuxième
degré le troisième degré de deuxième
degré il avait pleuré un soir je peux
acheter
vous savez je l'écris mais c'est vrai
que j'ai eu plus
plusieurs ça fait trois fois qu'on me
donne une récompense et je n'étais pas
la première fois que j'étais en direct
bah ça fait quelque chose quand vous
manquez conventionnés si vous n'aimez
pas c'est un acteur n'aime pas entendre
les rires
si un acteur n'est pas sensible ouvrir
si un acteur n'est pas sensible aux
applaudissements à l'accueil du public
il ya longtemps que je serais parti donc
on est en marche ou public et c'est pour
le public qu'on est là quand vous voyez
une salle qui se lèvent pas ce qu'on
vous dit vous avez un
vous avez une récompense vous la
regardez oui j'étais ému c'est vrai
annie girardot est venu avec son césar
vous n'êtes pas venu avec deux bagues
non parce que je vais vous dire il est
en vente
un classement là vous avez des projets
il était de notre côté nous j'ai pas
voulu perdre mais je n'ai pas là mais je
voulais dire non à niveau a dit que je
connais bien aux revenus bien depuis
elle ne peut plus quelques semaines je
crois que hier soir il ya eu une
péripétie ne sait pas à qui on la doit
mais ce truc se sont trompés sans le
faire exprès de catégorie et je vais y
aurait dû avoir un magnifique pour la
carrière
annie girardot justement cette carrière
qu'est ce qui s'était dit ah vous
revenez vous revenez vous revenez en
s'imaginant ça claude lelouch et des
misérables merci à claude lelouch mans
je lui ai dit d'accord mais avec lelouch
d'ailleurs j'ai fait même même trois
films là enfin bon les années qui ont
suivi
bon après je faisais moitié à mon jeu je
fais de la télévision fait ça de choses
je fais du théâtre
je suis très heureuse et tout mais en
effet c'est à cause vous avez des
projets maintenant de toute façon j'en
avais oui de faire un film finalement et
ça c'était avant même l'histoire des
césar est un film avec ce sera un
premier film quoi un premier comme on
dit en jargon dans notre métier
pour des films d'un metteur en scène qui
s'appelle grégoire delacourt voilà
michel serrault vous avez un projet avec
l'un des vainqueurs d'hier soir pour le
meilleur film
mathieu kassovitz jeunes vous allez
mieux renseigné que mon nom c'est signer
ou pas je ne sais pas il conclu vous
avez vu ce héros récemment vous avez vu
ce héros récemment oui c'est parfait
quand je parle non mais on en parle oui
c'est vrai mais je serai très heureux
parce que j'ai vu le film mais j'adore
le film et puis m'a tuer quelqu'un de
l'extraordinaire jeunes est magnifique
comédien grand metteur en scène c'est
trop tard et plus issus merci en tout
cas tous les deux d'être venu ce soir et
merci de nous avoir fait vivre la soirée
d'hier soir avec l'émotion il viendra la
prochaine fois et on essaiera de vous
faire rire beaucoup j'y compte bien on
va